in my village we are all fishers  this morning  dad is going fishing  he says he will come back in three days  but sometimes he stays for four or five  until he finds enough fish  it didn't used to be this way  grandpa was also a fisher and he was  always back for dinner  he loves to tell me stories about the  glittering schools of fish the turtles  he would see and the friendly giants  that swam by  sometimes in my dreams i visit grandpa's  reef and i imagine all the animals he  told me about  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  the future is in my hands grandpa would  say  just follow your heart  but i never really understood what he  meant  until much later  and the deep set you can go is 40 feet  so okay okay great  it's taken me a long time but i now have  a different relationship with the ocean  i take people out on my reef  and i've realized that grandpa's reef is  my reef too  our ocean just needs caring like how our  parents care for us  we can all do something  [Music]  you